look at this look at it look at it look
closer do you see what is there I have
to say that looks like someone kissed a
toilet but why all right so I just found
something crazy on Twitter there's this
picture that's going viral it's like the
outline of lips inside a toilet
why would somebody kiss a toilet I don't
understand why Jade
why would somebody kiss a toilet Sarah
have you seen this that's funny I know
exactly how this happened what it's
transference transference yeah what's
transferred
[Music]
like somebody kissed like a receipt or
like just as a relation that's the only
way I can imagine this happening what
were the other theory there was theories
that she vomited and went like minute
and like kind of kissed it
should we just annoy people around the
office and I mean they don't look like
they're doing anything they're probably
on Twitter anyway looking at this yeah
they're probably all talking about this
anyway right now I feel like we need a
good science mind do you have any
scientific theories as to how got there
a girl put her face to a toilet bowl but
why some people have freaky fetishes
that's what I was saying okay be and
then I'm freaky fashion is a lifestyle
odd fetish I seem to require it started
at home when I got a sudden urge to
kneel down and with the toilet clean not
just the seed but the room in the bowl
I'm upset already I don't want to lose
this so somebody could have wanted to
kiss it like in a sexual way I just hope
that they're using protection I would
say that this was probably a dare
someone definitely made $10 off of this
and which is upsetting because they
should have made it much more than yes
that's where poop goes I've seen toilets
this is where poopie goes wants to poop
twice to do what does that matter I am
familiar with this image I think the
first time I saw this image was on a
subreddit called reddit slash are slash
hmm which is like pictures that make you
think
I honestly think maybe someone had just
cleaned the toilet I'm not of the idea
and thought that this could be a funny
person image with the internet this is
the work of it this is a genius this is
purpose I think they knew this was
planted this was a planted I think so I
would have try to look up where I saw it
send that to you see if we get any more
all right thank you thank ya your
errands on the case I'm on it I'm on it
so I'm out in the streets now I got a
microphone just to look professional so
right now we are going to figure out who
kiss the toilet bowl can ask you a few
questions okay bad start can I ask you a
few questions real quick could I ask you
guys a few questions real quick all
right can I ask you a few questions
sure yep have you ever kissed the toilet
bowl never I try to stay as far as away
from it as possible okay so this is the
picture I need to know how it happened
oh [ __ ] that's in Russia you want me to
be graphic she was getting bent over and
hit the toilet bowl while she was
getting someone was having sex and just
kept kissing the toilet thing just I
don't know maybe ladies in love is that
a thing in Russia you can never know I
mean there's the classic drunken night
drunk at night is that like from
experience no that's not my shade of
lipstick we got a lot of theories we're
getting some dares some drunk some
fetish stuff no concrete answers Erin
just messaged me and she said that she
found this message I have done this
before I've a lot of oil-based lipstick
on toilet paper toss to toilet left
unflushed only to come back the next day
and then find the same phenomenon
someone's saying this is possible if the
toilet paper with the kiss is there for
a day so we're gonna have to test that
as well
she said she used oil-based lipstick
I've no I have no [ __ ] clue what that
means
also my lips are small so if this
doesn't ruin it oh this is not my color
Wow wait is that really man those are my
lips it looks like my mouth I've gotten
that mmm do I kiss like that okay too
close too close for comfort and I'm
putting it in hey Mike can you not pee
in the toilet for 12 hours cuz I'm doing
science
alright so it's the next morning and I'm
going to see whether the lipstick kiss
is still on my toilet my god
it's not a pretty kiss but lipstick is
on there it didn't look as good as the
photo so I'm gonna keep working I'm
gonna find the perfect combination so I
can have I can be positive that my
theory is correct Sarah what you're
smiling I got the answer oh you did yeah
I did too
so I tested it like a bunch of lipsticks
I transferred them onto this blotting
sheet and then I pressed it onto the
bowl you don't actually have to kiss the
toilet bowl in order to get the lipstick
kiss onto the toilet what
what
[Music]
yeah I'm not kissing a toilet okay